hé alors tu dis que de nouveau en état
d'arrestation pour le meurtre de Rolla Legrand se
tromper de gars j'étais avec elle oh
allez allons-y
ouais c'est un coup monté
dés un
millionnaire dure longtemps tu te portes
[Musique]
garde moi en vie
je souscrirai une évasion tu t'occupes d'
arranger quelque chose me dit tu peux être
tout à fait sauvage
tu es la propriété de l'
administration pénitentiaire de la Guyane française il n'y a
pas moyen de s'en sortir petit est un  comme
je sais que beaucoup d'entre vous pensent à
s'échapper, c'est votre meilleure chance, n'hésitez
pas à essayer quand vous le souhaitez, puis
venez avec vous, il y a deux Gardiens
qui sont toujours la Beauté buissonnée, quelle meilleure
chose qui puisse vous arriver est la
famine ou vous pourriez  choisissez de voir
quoi porter aux requins avez-vous toujours
réussi à survivre à votre première tentative
vous aurez deux ans en deuxième
tentative solitaire vous serez condamné à perpétuité à
Devil's Island
des choses étranges se produisent là-bas, en particulier
pour ceux qui cam  e pour aider
une fille fougueuse et une autre un autre
genre de vie
[Musique]
vous